monfort à tout ce nous sommes le lundi
23 mai merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale avec des invités
mais également les journalistes de la
rédaction nous commençons tout de suite
par les titres de cette édition
querelles au sein de la majorité de la
commune de plaisir jeudi dernier le
conseil municipal s'est déroulé sous
tension plusieurs élus ont perdu leurs
délégations pour s'être opposé à la
hausse des impôts locaux il fonde un
nouveau groupe nous y reviendrons les
lycéens seront ils bientôt fini au test
de dépistage du cannabis c'est ce que
propose le conseil régional
d'ile-de-france et sa présidente valérie
pécresse
pour nous en parler ce soir bruno myle
yens conseiller régional modem nous
reviendrons également avec lui sur le
revenu universel initiative soixante dix
huit clubs dont il est le fondateur
propose cette semaine à versailles un
débat sur le sujet et enfin cette
semaine nous vous proposons une série de
reportages le centre national du cinéma
nous sommes allés à la découverte du cnc
de bois d'arcy ou une partie du
patrimoine du cinéma et de l'image
animée et précieusement conservés et la
pénurie d'essence touche aussi les
yvelinois désormais plus de 10 % des
stations-service sont en rupture totale
ou partielle d'essence en france et
particulièrement dans le nord-ouest
cinq des 100 plus gros dépôt défense ont
bloqué et trois raffineries sont à
l'arrêt dans le pays un blocage qui a
été mise en place par les syndicats des
produits chimiques et du pétrole en
réaction au projet de votre travail via
l'utilisation du gouvernement de
l'article 49 3 pour le faire passer en
force
vous le voyez sur les images il fallait
se lever tôt pour avoir de l'essence
aujourd'hui sont concernés sur tout le
département des hauts-de-seine et des
yvelines en ile de france dans les
yvelines au chesnay à la celle saint
cloud et à rocquencourt les pompes se
vident très vite et les gens sont
inquiets nous sommes justement à l'aide
dans quelques stations service à la
rencontre des autres numbi liste saint
quentinois pour voir comment ils
appréhendent est justement cette rupture
cette pénurie d'essence regarder je
crois qu'il n'y a plus à y a plus rien
de contrôler dans ce pays alors on peut
s'attendre à tout va aux antilles on a
l'habitude
on gère on fait comme on peut mais on
gère bien là j'ai attendu avait pris une
bonne demi heure pour accéder à la pompe
c'est préoccupant effectivement donc
mais bon il faut mettre de l'eau dans
son vin comme on dit prendre son mal en
patience
il reste encore évidemment à des
stations essence à saint quentin en
yvelines qui vous rationneront mais
attention il ne peut pas parfois retirer
autant d'essence ce que l'on veut champ
politique à présent un conseil municipal
sous tension jeudi dernier à plaisir
plusieurs élus de la majorité ont perdu
leurs délégations pour s'être opposés
lors d'un précédent vote à la hausse des
impôts locaux dans le cadre de
l'élaboration du budget ils viennent de
fonder un nouveau groupe les détails de
wilfrid et richier et ça n'est pour dire
libre et indépendant c'est le nom du
nouveau groupe formé par cinq élus de la
majorité de la droite et du centre à
plaisir lors du dernier conseil
municipal à l'origine de cette scission
un vote celui de deux adjointes et d'un
conseiller municipal délégué qui se sont
opposés à la hausse des impôts locaux
lors de l'élaboration du nouveau budget
un choix que n'a pas apprécié la mère
joséphine coleman ce berger elle a donc
décidé de proposer qu'il soit démis de
leurs fonctions
quand on a une délégation d'adjoint et
qu'on se met volontairement dans
l'opposition forcément je suis obligé de
prendre en tant que maire des
responsabilités qui sont des
responsabilités et bien pour enlever la
délégation je les ai gardés sur le
conseil municipal
j'ai gardé cette ouverture en décembre
voilà j'espère et qu'il est soit dans la
majorité avec nous ils ont préféré
monter un groupe a paru bien écoutez
c'est pas grave c'est la politique et la
véronique guerre non séverine fille ou
perdre leur poste d'adjointe et ne
siégeront plus dans la majorité
elles ont été rejointes par trois autres
collègues et ont décidé de former ce
nouveau groupe
on se retrouve puni exclut donc à partir
de là on est obligé de répondre par
monter notre propre groupe
est-ce que vous avez vu
au conseil départemental lorsqu'ils ont
voté le budget le budget n'a pas été
voté à l'unanimité
depuis il y en a qui ont été expulsés y
en a qu à dénoncer c'est
antidémocratique maintenant j'affirme et
j'affirmerai mes positions
mes idées mais on réfléchit avec le
groupe que nous venons de créer au sein
de ce conseil municipal du 19 mai nous
allons continuer effectivement pour
essayer d'avoir le meilleur pour notre
ville et faire dire à ma mère
attention attention effectivement dit si
on comprenait l'opposition déplore la
situation parle d'une attitude peu
élégante et d'un manque de démocratie au
sein du conseil municipal concernant la
cause de ces tensions donc la hausse des
impôts la mère de plaisir affirme une
nouvelle fois ne pas avoir eu d'autre
solution face à la diminution des
dotations de l'état et samedi dernier le
chef le centre horticole d'enseignement
et de promotion situé entre tremblay sur
mauldre fêter ses soixante dix ans à
cette occasion une journée portes
ouvertes a été organisée pâtre grec de
discuter dixmude ciron d'ici l'été sur
classe regardez
rendez vous compte le chapeau aura formé
en 70 ans plus de 18 mille diplômés
le chef fête ses 70 ans samedi dernier
le centre horticole d'enseignement et de
promotion ouvrait ses portes au public
l'établissement est spécialisée dans la
formation aux métiers de l'aménagement
paysager mais aussi de la protection de
la nature on dispense donc des cours en
matière générale les cours de matières
générales donc avec d une approche un
peu théorique et puis ensuite on réalise
sur le terrain donc tous les chalets
dire tous les acquis
tous les acquis théoriques le programme
du chef a connu de nombreuses évolutions
se calquant sur les attentes du moment
mais aussi en anticipant les impératifs
de demain les métiers ont énormément
évolué nous étions au départ sur
l'horticulture ensuite sur du paysage
aujourd'hui sur de paysages et de
l'environnement
bien sûr nous répondons aux besoins des
professionnels mais également aux
besoins de la société où la place de
l'environnement et de la protection de
la nature est de plus en plus prégnante
le centre de formation ne perd pas de
vue son futur le projet quand ils
veulent qui mutualisera le chef et deux
autres centres de formation mais aussi
le projet d'un hébergement qui
accueillera jusqu'à 1000 élèves verront
bientôt le jour et nous accueillons avec
nous en plateau ce soir bruno milian
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes conseiller
régional d'ile-de-france à nous vous
invitons pour un sujet pour deux sujets
mais tout d'abord la région ile de
france qui adopte et donc jeudi 19 mai
la proposition portée par sa présidente
valérie pécresse les républicains de
financer des tests salivaires de
dépistage de drogue et des éthylotests
pour une liste des lycées en france et
dans afin de lutter contre les
addictions
c'est une décision dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment qui fait polémique
et elle fait polémique et c'est normal
ça je veux bien comprendre la drogue
dans les lycées c'est un fléau et yappa
d'aurélie c'est d'ailleurs il ya dans
les collèges aussi c'est un fléau il
faut quand même savoir que ça
considérablement augmenté depuis trois
ans 30 % d'augmentation c'est quand même
important 10 % des lycéens de ceux qui
rentrent en seconde fument au moins un
joint par jour donc c'est un problème à
la fois de prévention de santé publique
mais aussi un de décrochage scolaire
parce que vous savez très bien que ça
quand même un petit un petit impact sur
le cerveau alors y'a pas que cette
mesure là évidemment et puis c'est pas
fait sous la contrainte non plus c'est
sous le forme du volontariat nous on a
proposé un amendement que une
la présidente a bien l'exécutif a bien
voulu retenir qui est aussi d'avoir
recours à un mécanisme d' analyses des
eaux usées des lycées
c'est ça effectivement mais si on
revient juste sur cette décision alors
ça va il va falloir faire des études ont
été destitués test des dépistages ça va
coûter cher est ce que c'est le moment
d'investir autant d'argent
écoutez quand on a fait le budget on a
réduit le fonctionnement qui était trop
important mais ça c'est habituel dans la
gestion socialiste on va dire donc on a
réduit le fonctionnement parce que ont
trouvé que c'était trop énorme et ce
qu'on a réduit dans le fonctionnement
lamy dans l'investissement et les lycées
vous savez très bien les lycées en ile
de france n'est pas une nouveauté ils
ont été quand même malmené pendant la
dernière mandature et même au delà avant
donc on essaye de travailler énormément
là dessus non seulement dans leurs
améliorations au quotidien mais aussi
sur la prévention et sur le décrochage
scolaire le décrochage scolaire
ce ne sont pas que ce que vous aimez ce
qu'ont à dire les tests salivaires etc
on va beaucoup travailler aussi sur la
formation professionnelle a baissé de
laisser aucun lycéen de côté si on fait
ça c'est qu'il ya un vrai problème il
faut pas il faut arrêter de se voiler la
face
moi je ce que j'apprécie au moins avec
valérie pécresse même si on n'est pas du
même parti politique c'est qu'elle a été
élue sur un programme clair et ce
programme
elle le met en action alors ça ça gêne
beaucoup nos adversaires politiques dont
vous disiez tout à l'heure vous vous
aviez proposé donc un recours à un
mécanisme d' analyses des eaux usées
afin de rétablir au sto un diagnostic
flat fiable et anonyme
voilà de la consommation à des grèves
est-ce que vous des lycées est ce que au
sein du conseil régional les gens sont
plutôt d'accord avery pécresse le fn
parle justement dans ce match c'est à
propos bulls mais me parlez pas du front
national le front national depuis qu'il
siège au conseil régional ils n'ont fait
que s'abstenir ou voter contre ils ont
ils ont une fois ou deux voté pour mais
franchement ils sont là pour faire de la
posture ceux qui font leur image ils
sont d'accord sur rien donc le front
national pour moi aujourd'hui ce qu'il
apporte au conseil régional
c'est à peu près rien alors après il ya
les positions un petit peu idéologique
et dogmatique delà de la gauche que je
regrette parce qu'on pourrait s'entendre
si on fait un vrai plan d'action et on a
d'ailleurs proposé que ce soit élargi oc
en coopération avec les collèges parce
que ça commence dès le collège c'est
quand même très très inquiétant
on a quand même des élèves qui arrivent
au lycée le matin à 10 heures sous
l'emprise de l'alcool
comment voulez vous qu'ils réussissent
leurs études c'est pas possible il faut
qu'on arrive à faire sauter ce tabou
donc tout le monde parle depuis des
années ça remonte pas à hier moi je suis
grand père ça existait déjà du temps de
mes enfants vous imaginez ça ne fait
qu'augmenter ya un moment au moins nous
on a mis le sujet sur la table
alors évidemment ça plaît pas ça plaît
pas mais il va falloir qu'on fasse
quelque chose on peut pas laisser les
enfants s'autodétruire comme ça c'est
pas stigmatiser peut-être les lycéens
les cinq médecins en avance ils sont
stigmatisés visa après que ça va être de
parapher dangereux pour à la suite de
leurs études est donc complexe qu'il
faut qu'il comprenne ce qu'il faut
qu'ils comprennent qu'on stigmatise pas
les lycéens on a des études très
précises vous pouvez vous les procurer
j'ai pu les commentaires très
sincèrement mais on va les études
précises de à partir de quand ça
commence il ya déjà des des prises de
d'alcool et de drogue dès la 6è et dès
la 5eme donc c'est pas stigmatiser des
lycéens si on propose un élargissement
coopératif au département francilien
aussi sur cette action là c'est parce
qu'on veut prendre ce problème vraiment
à la source
il faut l'éradiquer moi je vais vous
dire un truc je fais un truc est pas
bien moi je suis fumeur
si à l'époque où j'étais au lycée on
m'avait de la loi evin avait existé
peut-être que je n'aurais jamais fumé
donc il faut quand même qu'on a qu'on
ait une action là dessus après c'est sûr
le vantail on met pas un pistolet sur la
tempe des gens le coût de l'analyse des
eaux usées ça c'est important parce que
ça va nous permettre de pouvoir faire le
focus sur certains lycées où il ya
vraiment des traces importantes à la
fois de molécules d'alcool on va dire ou
de ou de molécules de télé pour faire de
thc ou de drogues ou de cannabis
donc on pourra cibler aussi les actions
si justement donc à cette proposition et
tables d'hôtes et si tu vous savez parce
que elle sera effective mais elle a été
adoptée puisqu'on l'a votée on l'a voté
en plénière la semaine dernière d'après
faut que ça se mette en place il faut
qu'on venait le retour des proviseurs je
sais qu'il ya une partie du corps
enseignant qui est plutôt favorable à
cette mesure parce que eux aussi se sont
un peu démunis un peu abandonnés par
l'état pour être honnête par rapport à
ça parce que ces trafics de drogue on
les voit aux abords des lycées et qu'il
n'y a pas grand chose qui ait fait donc
ils veulent aussi eu être en mesure de
pouvoir agir de l'intérieur vous avez
consulté justement le rapport à faire
mais ça a été construit on a consulté
oui on a consulté le rectorat on a
consulté des proviseurs d'établissement
et tous nous disent qu'il ya un problème
c'est donc un moyen de prévention sera
le serbe y en aura certainement d'autres
on va pas abandonner les autres quand la
gauche hurle
scandale en disant on a quand même
toutes les associations qui font de la
prévention autour de la drogue au
tournant cole c'est pas vrai on
abandonne personne c'est un moyen de
prévention supplémentaire et c'est aussi
pour nous l'occasion de mettre le doigt
sur un vrai problème que tout le monde
cache pour l'instant alors qu'il est
connu de tous je vais vous êtes
également invités pour parler d'un
second un sujet qui on va aborder car
notre temps est compté donc pour parler
du revenu universel
alors voilà pour qu'on parle en ce
moment du revenu universel universel
pardon au mois d'avril un rapport a été
remis au premier ministre par le député
christophe sirugue qu'il défendrait la
création d'un revenu minimum de 400
euros distribués à toutes les personnes
en situation de précarité la fondation
jean jaurès qui est proche du ps aussi
va dans ce sens et c'est justement ce
sujet que vous abordez au sein de
l'initiative 78 lors d'un dîner débat le
26 mai à versailles c'est important
aujourd'hui de parler du rôle universel
c'est important parce que je pense qu'on
va souvent reproché aux hommes
politiques et aux femmes politiques de
ne pas anticiper les problèmes avant la
fondation jean jaurès et avant le député
il y avait eu un rapport du conseil
national du numérique qui a été en plus
on va dire entériné par le m haïti à
cambridge qui fait état de d'un grand
nombre de suppressions d'emplois d'ici à
2050 avec le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle et de la
robotisation alors je vais vous donner
des chiffres qui font peur mais si on le
prend à temps ça peut s'anticiper on
parle de 3 millions de suppressions
d'emplois d'ici à 2050 en france donc il
faut il va falloir qu'on repense un
petit peu notre système de protection
sociale et le revenu minimum d'existence
ou revenu minimum universel ou revenu
minimum de base appelée appelons ça
comme on veut il ya différentes
il ya différentes façons le nommer
l'idée c'est de se dire on va arrêter
toutes les toutes les aides qu'on fait
qu'ils sont comme ça a donné à droite à
gauche et on va en donner une seule mais
pour tout le monde
de la naissance à la mort tu vois là ça
va venir remplacer les allocations
familiales ça va venir remplacer pas mal
de choses il y aura que cette aide là
c'est suffisamment important pour que
les gens puissent vivre
oui c'est la bonne moyenne 150 euros
c'est la bonne moyenne
bon pour qu'ils puissent vivre et
suffisamment pas trop haut pour que ce
soit pas incitatif à travailler voilà
donc c'est un peu une idée ça
simplifierait les choses alors ça
s'articule aussi avec l'impôt à la
source la fin du foyer fiscal parce que
vous êtes obligés de prélever les impôts
là pour chaque individu
ça veut dire aussi revoir le barème
d'imposition n'ont pas à la hausse mais
crée de nouvelles revient sur les plus
riches continueront à perdre bien sûr
bien sûr nation donc on va on va
débattre de tout ça je dis c'est
important d'ailleurs il ya des gens
assez d'importance qui viennent puisque
y aura frédéric lefebvre qui est député
les républicains qui portent force ce
sujet là voilà il y aura également
benoît hamon qui vient le député de
trappes
il y aura pascal luciani boyer qui est
là une femme qui travaille conseil
national du numérique qui est fait
partie des gens qui ont remis le rapport
au gouvernement sur cette perte d'emploi
puis 2 2 personnages assez intéressant
françois-xavier au niveau qui est le
patron de l'association pour
l'instauration du revenu d'existence et
enfin eric verhaeghe qui est écrivain
qui est un ancien président de l'apec
est aussi un ancien administrateur la
sécurité sociale bien d'autres il ya
d'autres politiques justement qui parle
donc va du revenu unis
mersen qui met en place ce serait simple
c'est une simplification aussi
administratif c'est un peu d'argent en
termes de gestion de tout ça oui mais ce
qu'est ce ça ça semble demain peut-être
même dans 10 ans a baissé en france
quelque chose qui sont compliquées quand
même comme ça ça paraît utopique mais il
ya déjà des pays qui le mec qui le met
en oeuvre un dans les pays du nord je
n'ai pas chaque fois je me trompe je
sais jamais si la faf a lancé m
respectivement 2 novembre 2016 déjà en
test
c'est des gentes les pays bas envisagent
de le faire il ya un pays d'amérique
latine qui le fait en inde ils
commencent à le faire tous les pays
commencent à s'intéresser à ça d'abord
parce que c'est une simplification
extraordinaire de toutes les allocations
qu'on peut verser
et puis et puis c'est une simplification
la peau un revenu à la source avec
d'étranges qui commence à 2 3% toile et
jusque là je sais plus combien on dit
aujourd'hui 41 peut-être qu'on pourra
descendre un petit peu ce qui se fera
pas de mal pour ceux qui en payent
beaucoup mais mais voilà c'est une idée
en tout cas il faut pas la laisser de
côté il faut en débattre et voir si elle
est réalisable beaucoup pensent qu'elle
l'est beaucoup d'économistes pensent
qu'elle est ce que justement voilà on
voit que c'est plutôt les pays du nord
que ça commençait à émerger est ce que
la france est prêt pour ça qu'on voit ce
que soulèvent les contestations pour le
projet notre avis oui mais il ya un
moment je veux dire la france peut pas
rester à la traîne de tout on a été on a
été le pays des lumières on a été le
pays phare de l'europe pendant des
siècles et des siècles
et là on est à la traîne de toutes les
bonnes idées depuis 40 ans donc il
faudrait que ça change si on pouvait
s'emparer d'un sujet au moins et faire
partie du peloton de tête et bien ce
serait pas mal tout le monde justement
c'est les gens sont intéressés par le le
débat ce leur nuage reste deux places
alors il reste encore quelques places il
faut vous aviez sur le site d'initiative
78 contre ces initiatives 110 points
comme il ya un lien vous vous inscrivez
et puis vous venez nous rejoindre et
aucun problème les micros sont ouverts
pour tout le monde alors voila si le
revenu universel c'est une problématique
qui vous intéresse le débat est proposé
par initiative soit 118 ce sera jeudi 26
mai au bistrot du boucher à versailles
et merci beaucoup et il rêve de devenir
notre plateau et comme chaque lundi nous
allons parler culture nous devons une
page la culture avec et sephora namani
sephora qui nous a rejoint en plateau
bonsoir à vous vous venez me présenter
aujourd'hui pascal amoyel est ce que je
le prononce bien oui tout à fait il
offrait un spectacle samedi soir à
l'espace et philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois oui pascal amoyel c'est
ce pianiste virtuose que vous entendez
aussi bien sur france inter france
musique radio france et radio classique
il faut savoir que c'est très tôt qu'il
a montré des aptitudes pour
l'improvisation en clavier au clavier
sans même pour autant l'avoir étudié on
écoute quand j'avais une dizaine
d'années c'était en train de faire mes
gammes chez moi et c'est la gardienne de
mon immeuble qui est venu frapper à ma
porte et qui m'a dit je t'entends faut
jouer du piano
sais tu que dans le même immeuble il y
avait un grand pianiste appelé georges
cziffra et qui vient juste de déménager
il a ouvert une fondation pour les
jeunes à senlis et tu devrais peut-être
aller le voir c'est peut-être ton destin
alors cette rencontre elle est vraiment
déterminante dans la vie de pascal
amoyel car jobs
george's chiffre à vos présentera pour
lui toute sa vie un mentor d'ailleurs
dès son plus jeune âge pascal amoyel
suite ci fera aussi bien en france et en
hongrie
tout en exécutant parallèlement un
parcours musical rigoureux des dix ans
il commence ses études à l'école normale
de musique de paris il en sortirait avec
une licence de concert et entrera
derrière ou conservatoire national
supérieur de musique et de danse où il
obtient en 92 un premier prix de piano
puis même un premier prix de musique de
chambre et même le premier prix du
concours international des jeunes
pianistes de paris c'est d'ailleurs pour
lui le début d'une carrière
internationale qui l'a mal à se produire
en récital sur les plus grandes scènes
du monde alors la philharmonie de berlin
la cité de la musique la salle pleyel à
paris aux états unis en russie avec
l'orchestré symphonique d'état de moscou
également ou encore en chine au japon et
en 2005 pour pascal boyer c'est vraiment
la révélation au grand public en
remportant une victoire de la musique
dans la catégorie révélation soliste
instrumental et son palmarès ne s'arrête
pas là en 2007 son enregistrement
harmonies poétiques et religieuses de
liszt a été élu par la chaîne arte parmi
les cinq meilleurs disques de l'année en
2009 son interprétation des funérailles
de liszt et sélectionnés par le magazine
classica comme l'une des quatre
références historiques non vraiment ce
n'est pas rien et enfin en 2010 à
l'occasion du bicentenaire de la
naissance de chopin un grand prix du
disque décerné tous les cinq ans par la
prestigieuse société frédéric chopin à
varsovie pour son intégrale des
nocturnes de chopin
donc c'est véritablement un virtuose au
contemporain et les modernes aussi parce
qu'il s'est investi dans la création de
formes nouvelles de concert tout à fait
alors après le concert théâtral
qu'ils avaient crées bloc 15 ou la
musique en résistance qui a fait l'objet
d'ailleurs d'une adaptation pour france
télévisions il a créé pour le festival
de musique de la chaise dieu en 2010
quand même qu'il a représenté le
ministre de la culture de l'époque
frédéric mitterrand est la petite fille
du célèbre pianiste hongrois isabelle ci
fera donc l'incroyable destinée de
jogging cyfra où le pianiste aux cinq
ans doit un hommage donc à son mentor
cet enfant des bidonvilles du cirque de
budapest devenu soldat endroit en
résistance prisonniers j'ai les russes
envoyés en camps d'internement et puis
qu'on connaît par la suite pianiste
virtuose dans les bars de budapest
dès 1947 avec la carrière internationale
et donc pendant tout le spectacle
il va raconter l'histoire incroyable de
ce virtuose c'est un spectacle que j'ai
créée en 2010 au festival de la chaise
dieu qu'à créer georges ixe ifra et on
m'avait demandé de faire un hommage
hommage à cet homme et je me suis pris
un peu au jeu d'un spectacle musical pas
simplement d'un récit donc c'est
vraiment un spectacle et privés comme
des cours de comédie avec un acteur avec
christian fromont notamment qui est le
metteur en scène du spectacle
et voilà ça a donné une forme inédite et
je suis très très heureux de pouvoir
donner ce spectacle à la fois dans des
lieux d'un des festivals de musique
aussi dans des lieux où il n'y a pas
forcément de musique classique comme au
festival d'avignon
tayrac turan la hague et c'est alors
pourquoi justement avoir pensé à un
concert théâtral alors seul au but ça
lui permet justement de partager
davantage la musique classique de casser
les codes qui peuvent peut-être en
décourager certains de la rendre plus
accessible et ça lui permet également
d'intégrer des lieux dans lesquels on
n'attend pas forcément la musique comme
des théâtres où il a joué à guichet
fermé au théâtre du ranelagh à paris au
même des festivals comme celui d'avignon
le match va trop vite pour les pianistes
n'ont que dix doigts ici se produit au
pianiste pour cinq ans de doigts
il a vraiment à coeur de partager cette
passion raison pour laquelle il est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui professeur de
piano et d'improvisation au
conservatoire de rueil malmaison pour
s'investir auprès du plus jeune public
et pour ceux qui souhaiteraient
l'heureuse le retrouver dans un exercice
similaire et la clé fin 2015 un deuxième
spectacle le jour où j'ai rencontré
francis mon cher frédéric chopin
moi je suis en train de vaincre le piano
ou le fait chanter
il faut savoir que la notoriété de franz
liszt était tel que à côté
elvis presley ou les rolling stones
frais
pâle figure
france n'est pas heureux dans cette vie
de pianiste à 15 ans il va dire à sa
mère qui veut abandonner le piano
il se sent peu à peu aspiré par le
silence et donc tous ces effets sont là
pour prolonger un petit peu toute la
poésie même le roman et vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les dates de la tournée
internationale de l'art ti sur son site
à l'adresse et qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci beaucoup
sephora 12 avoir dressé le portrait de
celui qui s'est vu décerner en 2012 le
prix jean pierre bloch de la licra
récompensant un artiste et son oeuvre
dans son rapport aux droits de l'homme
il a été nommé chevalier dans l'ordre
des palmes académiques 2014 on vous
retrouve mercredi dans casque tout à
fait et on parlerait du festival les
clés du cinéma festival des
clayes-sous-bois avait justement on va
rester dans le cinéma maintenant le
premier reportage une série que nous
allons vous proposer tout au long de
cette semaine nous sommes allés à la
découverte du cnc de bois d'arcy une
partie du patrimoine du cinéma et de
l'image animée et d'entreposer dont cet
ancien enfant ou plus de 80 personnes
travaillent chaque jour à la collecte la
conservation l'inventaire ou la
restauration de films découverte des
lieux avec béatrice de pastres
directrice des collections william el
est dit mais square bien à l'abri dans
leur boîte
ici sur ses étagères ses pellicules sont
les témoins de l'histoire du cinéma
en tout ce sont plus d'un million de
bobines entreposés sur les deux sites du
cnc de bois d'arcy et du fort de saint
cyr un patrimoine inventorié restaurer
et conservé par le cnc la direction du
patrimoine du centre national du cinéma
et de l'image animée différentes
missions
d'abord la conservation des collections
film qui lui sont confiées dans le cadre
de dépôt volontaire c'est à dire des
producteurs des collectionneurs
des laboratoires qui ont confié des
supports filmique donc ses collections
confié vont être inventoriés vont être
surveillés conservés dans de bonnes
conditions
sur ce site de 5 hectares les bobines
sont numérisés restaurer et classés par
support avec trois grands silos de
stockage pour les supports dits de
sécurité
les films sont conservés à une
température moyenne de 10 degrés et un
taux d'humidité de 35 à 45%
le principe d'un centre d'art chine
c'est effectivement de pouvoir
accueillir toutes les expressions on va
dire du cinéma donc on a des films même
d'avant le début du cinéma
on est dans une salle de conservation de
des films sur support de sécurité c'est
à dire sur un support à 76 à cette appli
polyester c'est la pellicule qui est
aujourd'hui le support de conservation
même du numérique étant donné qu'on ne
sait pas conserver de façon pérenne le
numérique aujourd'hui la pellicule
polyester a une durée de vie d'à peu
près 300 ans
le ce que vous avez dans votre caméra a
priori cette cassette sa durée de vie
elle était de 5 6 ans dans d'autres
espaces sont conservés les films les
plus anciens sur un support en nitrates
une matière hautement combustible qui
nécessite une conservation toute
particulière là on est à peu près à
entre 10 et 12 degrés et puis un taux
d'humidité un petit peu plus un peu plus
élevé donc voilà ce qu'il nécessite
les bâtiments étaient peu différent on
va aller voir une l'intérieur d'une
cellule
ce sont parfois des trésors inestimables
que l'on peut trouver dans ces cellules
des trésors qui ont parfois plus d'une
centaine d'années comme ce film de 70 mm
des frères lumière tournée lors de
l'exposition universelle dans les
perforations soit un petit peu un petit
peu abîmés mais à part ça l'image et le
support sont encore dans un état
exceptionnel
on voit là ce film à 116 ans la
collection nitrates représente environ
un tiers de la totalité des pellicules
conserver au cnc des bobines surveiller
sauvegarder un véritable travail de
fourmi car le patrimoine du cnc ne
s'arrête pas seulement au cinéma et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis tout de suite vous
retrouver michael elle me d'euros pour
le 7-8 sport quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du journal je vous souhaite donc
une excellente soirée
vous
ce